hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game a lot of you have been
requesting since it happened yesterday
in the round six of the us chess
championship it's samuel savion versus
fabiana carwana and uh both of them uh
we're having uh we're having a pretty
good tournament uh they both lost one
game uh semyon uh savion in round five
lost uh lenderman uh and caruana of
course in the game that we've shown uh
to daniel naroditsky uh here uh fabi has
the black pieces he's gonna try to
bounce back and we have the uh four
nights opening so that's going to be
very enjoyable uh let's check it out as
samuel opens with uh e4 uh we have e5 by
fabi knight to f3 knight to c6 and now
knight to c3 we have knight to f6 uh
going for the four knights game uh
interestingly uh knight to c3 is the
three nights the game or the three
nights opening but no one ever plays
anything here other than um a knight to
f6 so i don't think
anyone ever played anything here other
than knight to f6 because it's so
enjoyable seeing all of the four knights
out
this early on the board uh and okay uh
we have d4 by savion and fabi goes for e
captures on d4 and now knight captures
on d4 if you remember uh the game is
from the 1952 uh second soviet team cup
uh that mikhail thal played against yuri
averbach we've mentioned this game many
times uh it's the game that won mikhail
tal his grand master title he played
knight to d5 this is the so-called
belgrade gambit and it's very very
complicated and there's a lot of horsing
around average played knight to b4 then
thought captured on d4 then avribak
captured an e4 and look at this i mean
it's a complete mess
remind me to show this game one time
because it's uh well it's just very
enjoyable but okay after he captures on
d4 we have knight captures on d4 uh this
is the uh
most common reply here uh the belgrade
gambit is still being played even today
in 2021 but this is played much more
often so bishop to b4 pinning the knight
and now knight captures and c6 we have b
characters in c6 and now bishop to d3 so
savion can be continues development uh
as there was the threat of just
eliminating the knife and picking up
this pawn maybe uh you you never wanna
try something like this because you
might lose your knight but okay queen to
e7 can be played and then it's fine so
both players just castle castles castles
and now d6 by fabi we have bishop to g5
pinning the knight and now h6 fabi not
afraid he's gonna go all the way we have
g5 bishop to g3 and now the position has
been reached before rook to e8 is a
normal bishop g4 is a known move some
other moves are also known but here uh
we have queen to e7 by fabi and it is uh
as of move 11 that we have a completely
new game
uh so let's see how seven continues the
uh the e4 pawn is still being pressured
we could always just capture the knight
and then pick up the pawn however he
offers the pawn he plays knight to a4
now can you really capture this pawn uh
well you could for example knight
captures an e4 we can play rook to e1
because the bishop covers that but then
we play c3 we kick away the bishop but
then of course the black doesn't move
the bishop black just captures on g3 for
example f captures on g3 and if now
bishop to a5 we can bring our queen to
f3 bring this rook to e1 and we have a
full development basically okay we have
a funny knight on a4 but other than that
uh
we're very good here the queen and the
bishop are doing a fine job uh white
should be better here but it's hard to
say of course black has the bishop pair
so it's a it's a very tricky position uh
however after knight to the a4 fabi
doesn't go for this he goes bishop to a5
he wants to shift the bishop over to
this diagonal right away c3 now of
course the pawn cannot be captured
because if now uh knight captures pawn
then rook to e1 just wins if for example
d5 we're going to play b4 and after
bishop to b6 we can simply eliminate the
bishop and after something captures f3
just wins the night so that can be
played b4 also prevents something like
queen to c5 check so instead after c3 we
have bishop back to b6 right away and
now savion just captures we have knight
captures a captures
and the queen to e2 now the pawn is
nicely defended and bishop to g for
attacking samuel's queen on e2 the
bishop is developed the rooks are
connected and queen to e3 now uh knights
the h5 going after the bishop also maybe
f5 is is an idea in some lines you have
to be careful d5 also
so here
we have f4 by white and now fabi has to
figure out how to go about this position
uh fabi plays d5 here and it's a very
active move but it's a very very
dangerous move a safer
move would be uh just moving back the
bishop with something like bishop to d7
or even bishop to c8 but it's hard to
understand why right away we're gonna
get to this but just in case you guys
are interested after bishop to d7 it
doesn't matter for example if f captures
h captures and that's it that the
position is fine however after five
played d5 now it's a completely
different story now we have f captures
on g5 and now you can no longer play h
captures on g5 because by playing d5 you
opened up this diagonal and now the c7
bishop is hanging so we can just capture
it uh and now what do you do here if
queen captures we can simply capture
this and i do you see the problem of
this bishop being on g4 uh yeah that's
that's the problem once the king moves
we're just going to pick it up so after
f characters on g5 we have knight
captures and g3 by fabi queen capture
sun g3 and queen captures on g5 so now
what do you do of course we uh chase the
queen back with h4
queen to g7 you can't really put the
queen on a light square because then e5
or captures just opens up a discovery so
queen captures on c7 grabbing that pawn
and now uh samuel is ready to start
picking off all of those pawns we have
d4 by fabi hoping for a nice capturous
captures but uh here we just have c4
uh we have rook f2c8 going after fabi's
queen aft after samuel's queen and now
not going for b6 because if we capture
this then locate the b8 then we go after
the b2 pawn so you don't want to
activate the black species you want to
keep them at base so the queen back to
d6 and now we have c5 so nicely
defending everything and as always if
queen captures we can just play this
pick up the b2 pawn so now fabi has a
past d4 pawn and it could be very
dangerous but here comes rook to f6
going after the
h6 pawn but now fabi plays bishop to h3
now it's fabi who's threatening
checkmate here uh rook to f2 only good
move to prevent this and now king the h8
fabi doesn't care about any pawns here
he just wants to play rook to g8 and
continue the attack against the white
king
and here a defensive move like queen to
h2 to kick away the bishop can
be played definitely but uh savion just
plays queen captures on b6 and this is
beautiful because he just
tells fabi do your thing it doesn't work
and that's you know to someone like fabi
that's a pretty big thing to say so here
fabi goes rook to g8
now seemingly threatening bishop
captures on g2 but not really here we
have e5 and e5 is such a beautiful
defensive attacking idea that uh well
you just have to see it to believe it uh
now comes rook 8 e8 and i know what you
guys are wondering you're wondering but
why not bishop captures on g2 well
that's an excellent question but it's
also the one that you will have to
answer for yourselves so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
white while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on solving this
incredible hypothetical situation and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook captures on f7 now
you see the power of the e5 move and how
black is completely helpless here
there are no discoveries because
wherever you move the bishop we just win
the queen uh if you play something like
queen captures on f7 then queen captures
an h6 check queen has to block only move
and then queen captures and h7 is
checkmate and even if you don't capture
the rook if you move the queen somewhere
it doesn't really matter where then even
the rook to h7 is checkmate the bishop
nicely covers the h7 square so this is
the idea behind the queen captures on b6
it wasn't just a pawn grab it was a pawn
grab that said uh fabi uh your rook to
g8 idea is you know
it's just nothing
but of course he has to try so rook
eight to e8 he continues and now rook to
e1
nicely defending this pawn uh we have f5
now and now by playing f5 you block the
light square bishop and now the uh you
have to be careful now bishop captures
on g2 is definitely a threat uh and here
we have bishop back to f1 nicely
defending that g2 pawn twice now we have
f4 fabinho wants to play f3 and open up
um uh black white's king side but now
even queen captures on c5 saying i'm
just gonna grab another point you got
nothing here uh favi has to keep trying
he pushes f3 but now just e6
and i mean what is this he he's he's
allowing fabi whatever fabi wants but
it's just not enough uh fabi plays f
captures on g2 interestingly if bishop
captures and g2 you also don't care you
just capture and after pawn captures and
now you're going to use fabi's own pawn
as a shield you're going to play e7 and
there is no move that black can make
here this is completely lost for black
even though it kind of looks nice you
have a pass pawn here you have passport
here you have a nicely doubled queen
rook uh a battery here on the g file but
whatever you do it's just game over or
rather there's no move you can make uh
the queen has to keep an eye on the d4
pawn the rook can't really move uh this
rook doesn't have anywhere to go if you
just make a king move queen d5 and now
rook f7 is coming i mean it's uh king h8
to prevent this you're still gonna play
rook f7 and if the queen moves just
queen e5 check and that's a game over
for example rook g7 rook to f8 with
check hoping to get a queen into the
game and now after king h7 even h5
taking away the last square from the
queen
to defend the rook on e8 and that's it
completely winning from savion so fabi
can't capture with the bishop he
captures with the pawn here but now we
just moved the bishop and the idea is
the same we're going to use our our
opponent's pawn to help us defend our
own king
so here bishop captures an e6
eliminating another pawn and now queen
the e5 7 offers a queen trade uh there
was a quicker way to to win the game
with something like rook after e2 but
it's a it's a tricky move and uh how do
you defend the bishop
uh
of course you can't really just move the
bishop and trade everything we're up
material so we're gonna win the uh when
the end game we can just start pushing
our pawns and we don't really care and
uh you can't move the queen this is
hanging you can't really defend it you
could play something like queen g4 not
to try and keep an eye on everything but
then bishop f5 for example completely
crushing there's no no move black can
make here
so uh you know there are there there was
that in the position but okay after
queen a queen to e5 offering a queen
trade fabi i think happily traded queen
captures rook captures and now bishop to
h3 continues to defend his um well
beautiful pass pawn on g2 rook to e4 now
going after this spawn and now uh fabi
trades with rook captures and maybe this
capture was a bit premature because it
only helps white get another attacker
onto that g2 pawn so maybe waiting a
little bit but it's it's a really
difficult position and it's still only
moved 35 we have to reach move 40 to
gain uh more time for for time control
so rook capture sun e4 was played bishop
captures and now there's really no way
to defend this fabi plays d3 he offers
this pawn to make
to try and make this pawn last a little
bit longer bishop captures on d3 and now
rook to e8 trying to create some uh
problems here but now bishop to e2 you
could also play rookie two bishop to e2
is a bit more classy king to g7 and now
a4 now those three past pawns are just
monsters and it's not going to be easy
stopping them uh so now you could go for
rook to b8 go after this pawn but the
bishop just moves the the pawn is
defended we're going to capture this
pawn so not not a lot here you could
continue like some like rook to b4 we're
going to capture on g2
and now it doesn't really matter if you
capture we're going to capture and now
you could capture one pawn but it's not
enough uh
and also you're in check you have to
move the king and then you know we just
continue pushing so it's too many pawns
uh simply too many pawns uh so after
rook uh this move we have rook to e3 by
fabi and now a5 you don't have to worry
about rook to a3 the a2 the b2 pawn
prevents this rook to e5 going after the
pawn now comes the b4
uh on move 41 we have rook to e3 and now
rook to f3 and he was in this position
animal 42 that fabiano caruana resigned
the game
and a wonderful and incredible win for
samuel savion so here you can see that
it wasn't uh
so much uh of uh fabi trying to go for
more as it might have seemed in the game
against nardinsky this was he was just
completely outplayed here by savion
in this four nights openings uh opening
so yeah i mean the the the four nights
of the apocalypse right again it would
seem uh but it was it's such an
impressive game and uh he just allowed
fabi to do whatever favi wants but it
simply wasn't enough there was nothing
he could do and here you you don't
really have a move if you trade rooks
for example captures captures then who's
going to stop those pawns your bishop is
just a monster here guarding all of
these squares and if you trade minor
pieces also doesn't really matter
you could capture this rook captures
here i mean it's still uh four pawns the
two uh this is uh
this is two winning i mean uh you you
just have to put the rook behind any of
those pawns and just push it and you
know they're really you don't even need
a winning plan to win this
yeah after rook to f3 uh fabio resigned
and an incredible victory for samuel 7
in this
round seven of the uh
us chess championship so currently the
leaders are alexander lenderman and ray
robson followed by wesley so uh
dominguez and samuel savion here with
three and a half points the leader have
four points so a lot could still happen
we'll see uh but uh from the from the
favorites wesley so is definitely still
in the race fabi i think now is
definitely out of the race uh but you
know uh we'll see
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it really really an
impressive one uh on so many levels that
trick where he allowed fabi to just i
mean it's uh beautiful it's just amazing
here where he allowed this bishop to g2
you have to find this queen captures b6
e5 and then to allow this i mean you
really have to find this
but yeah hope you guys enjoyed this uh i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to ayad habib uh and i would like to
thank tom carr tom darrell of francis
air and mr hoodie guy for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of
the usgs championship checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day